right now that certainly was the most
significant and exciting of all the
things that I've done in space I mean
both as an astronomer and an astronaut
to put my two hands on the the greatest
telescope in the world up in space I
mean what a what a thrill boom what's up
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host Don sake on very excited to still
be at MIT in Cambridge in Massachusetts
we are at building 33 we are gonna be
talking about being a NASA astronaut and
also Space Systems design we have dr.
Jeffery Hoffman joining us on the show
hello I could be with you thank you so
much for coming on it's such an honor
and a pleasure we're very grateful to be
able to sit down with you and talk to
you
looking forward good thank you thank you
for those who don't know dr. Jeffery
Hoffman is a former NASA astronaut
flying in five missions with over 50
days of time and space he was inducted
into the astronaut Hall of Fame in 2007
and is now a professor of Aeronautics
and Astronautics at MIT co-director of
the Massachusetts Space Grant consortium
an author of an astronauts diary which
contains excerpts of original recordings
he made with a pocket tape recorder and
you can find his link right below in the
bio Jeff let's start things off with one
of our favorite questions we like asking
people we find ourselves as stewards of
Earth what is your current take on the
state of humanity well it's interesting
that you mentioned stewards of Earth
because one thing that you do get as an
astronaut is a new perspective on planet
Earth you know before I went up I grew
up I was in in school in the 60s the
birth of the ecology movement Earth Day
all that I mean I always knew
intellectually the earth is finite we
have to protect our resources all the
things that that we talked about
problems that have only become worse in
the subsequent 50 years but somehow when
you actually go up there and you can see
the earth as a planet and and you you
feel the finiteness of the planet
because you're going around it every 90
it's and you look at the atmosphere
which you go out on a nice sunny day and
you look up at the big blue sky and it
looks like it goes on forever and you
can sort of understand how it it was
hard for some people to get the idea of
the finiteness of Earth the finiteness
of our atmosphere the fact that if you
keep putting more and more carbon
dioxide into the atmosphere eventually
it's going to have an impact but you go
up in space and you see how thin that
layer of the atmosphere is it is finite
we can't just do anything we want to our
planet and expect that it's not going to
have an impact it's having an impact and
you can now see the impact of humanity
from a global cosmic perspective really
and you know it's like how many people
have seen pictures of the Grand Canyon I
mean it's magnificent this huge hole in
the earth and intellectually you
understand you see the strata you know
that that's the history over the last
few billion years but man when you go
there and you're in the bottom of the
canyon and you're looking up that the
emotional impact is it's just
overwhelming it and that's what comes
from being in space so you know the
current state of the earth you know on
the one hand there's lots to be
pessimistic about you know you know are
we really going to be able to get our
hands around climate change and stop the
the sea level from rising I I have great
doubts just because I mean there's so
many countries involved the population
is still growing but on the other hand
there's a lot of things to be optimistic
about growth of interesting technologies
the improvements in in health care
genomics the ability to cure a lot of
diseases and so like I suspect most
times in human history there
times there are things to be optimistic
about things to be pessimistic about you
know I think Humanity is going to
survive one way or the other you never
know
back at the height of the Roman Empire
people probably thought that that kind
of life and technology was going to go
on forever and and who knew and you know
we kind of imagined our civilization is
going to go on for forever and and just
keep on improving we could have a
worldwide famine we could have you know
famine disease wars pestilence I mean
the Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse so
to speak so I don't know
I suspect things are gonna hopefully be
pretty peaceful and for the rest of my
life
I'm concerned for my grandchildren but
you know just like we've had to take
care of the world in our lifetimes that
gets passed on to the next generation
and and all we can do is try to make
their job as as easy as possible which
we're not doing right now unfortunately
what a profound realization to be able
to take the the animals the humans on
from the planet to put them into orbit
every 90 minutes and have that
perspective for the first time in just
the last 50 years be augmented to have
that that style of awe and and a
comprehension of our place in the cosmos
and being able to see the anthropic
scene actually happening with some of
the deforestation or acidification and
things of that so yeah deforestation I
mean over the course of my five space
flights I could see the progressive
cutting down at the Amazon rainforest
for instance it's scary you see all of
the agricultural burning that's going on
to create fields where the trees have
been cut down you see how because of the
need for firewood in developing
countries that the
vegetation on on hillsides the the line
of trees goes further up because as they
have to go further up to cut the wood
down harbors getting silt up silted up I
mean there's there's a lot of a lot of
problems which you you get a different
perspective on when you see them from
outside yes yes and we hope and feel as
though the millennials in the gen Z and
further are gonna take that stewardship
very seriously and solve some of these
biggest challenges that we have ahead of
us Jeff let's talk about your journey so
born in New York City and then ended up
going through astronomy at Amherst and
then PhD in astrophysics at Harvard and
then also masters and material science
of rice getting involved in in and
getting inspired by science and space
tell us about how that process happened
well I was born in New York City and
lived there for the first seven years
then we moved up to the suburbs but
frequently went back into the city and
you know my parents were very good about
exposing me and my brothers to a lot of
cultural aspects in the city we went to
concerts museums and including the
planetarium the Hayden Planetarium and
yeah I don't know exactly what it was
but I guess my dad was kind of
interested in astronomy as well he had a
little two-inch refracting telescope and
and and he knew quite a lot so he
enjoyed taking me of the planetarium and
I guess he noticed that I I seemed
somehow to react to it I was fascinated
by how the planets moved and and I
learning the names of all the
constellations and now that was back in
the 1950s that's how old I am and
and it was also the the dawn of the
coming Space Age we had never you know I
was a kid before we launched Sputnik
even but there was a lot of writing in
the newspapers and magazines and shows
on television about how pretty soon we
were gonna have rockets that could orbit
the earth and satellites and and my
boyhood heroes were Flash Gordon Buck
Rogers because there were no real
astronauts at the time but that that
came and and so yeah I remember I was in
junior high school when Sputnik was
launched and dad took us out to the high
school football field to watch this
incredible thing fly over which now I
mean we see satellites all the time we
don't think much of it but that first
time it was amazing and then when people
started to go in space you know Yuri
Gagarin Alan Shepard John Glenn and I
mean it was all over the news everywhere
and you know every red-blooded American
boy unfortunately we didn't have the
astronaut role models for girls at the
time we do now luckily we have lots of
women astronauts but in any case we all
wanted to be astronauts when we grew up
sure why not I mean I was I was
fascinated by by that however it became
apparent pretty soon that that all of
the early astronauts were military
pilots test pilots mostly and and that
was not a career for me but my interest
in space you know from the planetarium
and and just reading and that continued
I did well in school and all the
subjects but I particularly liked
science and math and and and astronomy
so I I went to Amherst College and I
took the beginning astronomy course I
still enjoyed it and so I took all the
physics and math courses that you need
for astronomy which is basically as
physics through a telescope and a few
astronomy courses as well and then went
to graduate school the kind of astronomy
that I was most interested in was
space-based astronomy looking at
high-energy radiation I mean we get all
our information
almost all our information about the
universe by electromagnetic radiation
light of course is the easiest that gets
through our atmosphere as do radio waves
but high-energy radiation x-rays gamma
rays I mean it was interesting from a
scientific point of view first of all
because they're created in some of the
most energetic parts of the universe
really high magnetic fields super high
temperatures stellar explosions I mean
cool stuff basically so and
scientifically it was interesting
because it was new we had just gotten to
the point of being able to send x-ray
and gamma-ray telescopes up above the
atmosphere and so it had the added in
addition to the intrinsic interest in
this type of radiation it had the added
interest that when you're doing
something for the first time you're
looking at a new part of the spectrum
you're almost guaranteed to find new
things and of course the early days of
x-ray astronomy were very exciting
continues to be actually we're in a
Golden Age of astronomy these days and
so I was working basically with with
space technology designing telescopes
that we launched from my PhD it was it
carried up by a high-altitude balloon I
went and did a postdoc over in England
at the University of Leicester and there
we we use sounding rockets that would go
up above the atmosphere but only stay up
for five to ten minutes at a time and
started work on satellites as well which
then I came back and was working at MIT
in the Center for Space Research
basically designing satellites to put up
designing x-ray telescopes to put up in
satellites and analyzing data from them
and we had some really exciting
discoveries probably the most
interesting this was back in the late
70s what we call x-ray burst that was
probably the the most fascinating part
of my astronomical career these are you
look at these x-ray sources and
they they're sort of going along not
doing very much and then all of a sudden
boom and there's this huge flash of
radiation which gradually dies away but
then you know a certain amount from
minutes or hours or days later on semi
periodically boom again and what we
finally after a lot of observations
unraveled the mystery
these are neutron stars which are
orbiting around other stars sucking
hydrogen onto the surface of the neutron
star where it gets compressed by the
gravitational field and eventually it's
compressed enough that it triggers
nuclear fusion so it's it's like a big
hydrogen bomb ten miles in diameter so
quite fascinating and you know I was
prepared to go on with my astronomy
career and and was just about at the
point where I was going to be looking
for a tenure-track position to become a
professor eventually by that time by the
way I was married I I married an English
woman when I was living over there and
and our oldest son was born in England
now we were living in Cambridge I was
working in Cambridge we were living in
the Boston area
thinking you know this would be a nice
place to spend the rest of our lives and
Along Came NASA in the mid to late 70s
let's let's we'll get there in a moment
okay you want to know how we know she
had a little more time on okay just in
crazy coolness of of x-ray and gamma-ray
astronomer because you spent so much
time on this seven years yes seven years
of time and also it continues to be like
you said a big renaissance in astronomy
so you were explaining how it's it's
like a binary or a triple star system
potentially multiple star system and one
of the stars is larger than the other
star and it's one of the stars is not
larger physically it's smaller it's yes
the neutron star is only maybe ten miles
in diameter but it's got a lot of
gravity and it has the mass of a big
star as the mass right what well what
happens is you know you have a star like
our Sun
and there's a balance the the nuclear
fusion inside the center of the Sun
creates a lot of heat it wants to push
everything out and gravity wants to suck
it back in and it's in a nice balance
once you use up all the fuel that you've
burned your hydrogen you maybe burns
burn the helium but eventually you've
burned out the fuel then our Sun will
collapse into a white dwarf and at that
point it's actually the Pauli exclusion
principle prevents all the electrons
from getting into one place and and that
creates an outward pressure so the the
white dwarf is is much smaller than than
our Sun and that's about all that's
gonna happen to our Sun it's gonna throw
off some some big shells that will
eventually burn up the earth and but
that's not for a few billion years so
don't lose any sleep over it
but if our Sun weighs the mass if our
Sun were bigger if a star is bigger then
it has more gravity when it collapses
and it can actually push those electrons
which were holding apart the white dwarf
can push those electrons right into the
nuclei and so the protons combined with
electrons to make neutrons and you you
end up with a huge atomic nucleus 10
miles in diameter that's a neutron star
it has to be several times more massive
than our than our Sun it's I mean any
incredible concept that you can have
this and and so on the surface of the
neutron star the gravity is is quite
strong and if it's in orbit around
another star like a you know a bigger
star with an atmosphere it can actually
suck the atmosphere off that other star
and as that gas falls onto the neutron
star it heats up and gives off if you
take millions of degrees really and
gives off x-rays and you can all you
there's other ways to make x-rays I mean
you can if you have strong magnetic
fields and you get charged particles
moving around a magnetic field they can
create electromagnetic radiation as well
and you get a strong enough magnetic
field and sand powerful electrons you
can make x-rays as well it's all very
high energy high temperatures cool stuff
yes and then briefly teach us about how
to do x-ray and gamma ray analysis
versus this is versus a big old mirror
for reflecting the light on a telescope
what does it look like on for x-ray
gamma ray well the the early days of
x-ray astronomy the x-ray detectors
really came out of nuclear physics in
fact my PhD thesis advisor originally
was a nuclear physicist but you know
they they adapted these x-ray gamma ray
detectors to astronomy and the only way
you could figure out where the x-rays
were coming from would be to make
collimators if you imagine you know like
a gun barrel but lots of them stacked
together so that when you look through
them it's like looking through a soda
straw and so if you see an x-ray you
know where it's coming from but it was
pretty crude you couldn't get good
images for x-rays as long as they're not
too energetic it was discovered that you
could actually make a mirror that would
focus x-rays not by bouncing them off
directly like light because the x-rays
would be absorbed but if you have it at
a very shallow angle the x-ray will hit
it and then bounce off and if you have
just the right shape double mirror
parabola and hyperbola you can actually
focus an image with x-rays and and that
was the real breakthrough in x-ray
astronomy that we could take pictures of
objects in x-rays and and we had there's
been a succession of x-ray telescopes
culminating in the current Chandra x-ray
Observatory which is a large x-ray
telescope and it's just been spectacular
and and what we can do now in astronomy
which is one of the reasons why why it's
a golden age of astronomy is we have
these telescopes throughout the
electromagnetic spectrum so you can get
radio pictures of something and and you
know radio waves are created by certain
processes and then you can get infrared
and optical and ultraviolet and x-ray
and gamma ray each of which gives you
different type of information about
what's going on out there and and so we
have this broad spectrum astronomy which
we can do now
plus much bigger telescopes Hubble
telescope which important part of my
life is still going strong and and some
super big telescopes that have been
developed on the ground together with
the ability to get around some of the
distorting image of images created by
the Earth's atmosphere I mean it's it's
almost incredible what what earthbound
astronomers are able to do now
so in astronomy it's really exciting
yeah yes it's been like you said it's
the a big big renaissance happening with
a lot of exponential technology the
broad caught the cosmic imaging that's
happening across all different parts of
electromagnetic spectrum so interesting
and also more trips up to space higher
tech equipment and better equipment on
the ground then you end up being
selected by NASA in 1978 well what
happened when the early astronauts were
selected and I I saw that they were all
military pilots which was not a career
for me I figured oh yeah flying in space
that'd be really cool but I never looked
down it as a realistic career prospect
you know I was going to be an astronomer
and do high-energy astrophysics but
along comes the Space Shuttle which NASA
was testing in the mid to late 70s with
the the drop tests of the enterprise
and getting ready they thought to launch
the first orbital shuttle in 1979 and
they needed new astronauts but the
about the shovel they had a crew of up
to seven people and they only needed two
pilots and so that's what really opened
things up for scientists medical doctors
engineers so when I was working at MIT
in the late 70s and and NASA put out a
call for new astronauts and when I saw
that they're looking for scientists Wow
you know this is yeah I always dreamed
of doing this and all of a sudden it's
no longer an unrealistic it now becomes
a realistic goal and I put in my
application and I was lucky I got
selected the first time around I mean
some people have I know one of one of my
colleagues applied four times before he
got selected but I was in the first
group of space shuttle astronauts that
was the group that came in with the
first American women Sally Ride and her
colleagues and and all of us flew 35 of
us and we all flew at least once I was
fortunate I stuck around and ended up
with five flights and I was very
fortunate yeah and okay so this what
does the team this first crew of 35 you
what do you go through what are the
operations and the trainings and what
does this all look like well when we
showed up nobody had flown on the
shuttle before and it that it was very
different from when a group of
astronauts showed up you know 20 years
later because by that time we knew how
the shuttle operated we knew how to
train people for the shuttle I mean
nobody actually knew how to train us we
originally we got trained by engineers
who had built the shuttle and they would
tell us how you know this piece of
equipment was made out of 1327 aluminum
and
you know these are the kind of rivets we
use I mean no we don't need to know that
we're operators and actually given my
educational background one of the after
our initial training we clearly weren't
gonna fly for a while I mean the shuttle
did not fly in 79 it didn't fly until 81
and there were a lot of older astronauts
who were gonna fly before our group so
we were all given on the job assignments
one of my first assignments was testing
out the shuttle software and a software
lab out at in in Downey California where
the shuttle was was built but another
job that I got I think given my
educational background and the fact that
I had worked at a university was to work
with the training people and actually
develop techniques for how to train us
so I actually wrote one of the training
manuals that was for quite a few years
was was used just to show the people you
know this is the sort of information
that we need as astronauts we are
operators we have to have a very broad
knowledge of many many different systems
and in the shuttle or whatever
spacecraft were flying on very different
from the engineers who work in Mission
Control where you have you know one
person who's responsible for the
propulsion system and has to have a
really deep knowledge of that system but
he doesn't necessarily have to have a
deep operational knowledge of how the
electrical power system works although
that may influence the propulsion
because all these systems are
interconnected but you know basically
the astronauts need a broad but maybe
not quite so deep Adhan knowledge as the
working engineers we need to know how to
operate a system we need to know what
kind of failures can occur and then of
course what do we do if something fails
yes so the major thing is to know the
protocols for the operations of Space
Flight
and to be very familiar with all of
those processes and in many cases when
we're working with new systems we have
to develop the processes
and that that was one of the the things
I spent a lot of time on was given my
scientific background I I would often be
assigned to work with scientists who
were designing experiments to be done in
space and given my knowledge of the
shuttle systems and the environment of
weightlessness I could often see things
about the way they had designed their
experiment you know given that they
weren't familiar with operating in space
things that weren't going to work
properly and and so I could offer ways
to to fix them in fact one of one of my
most important jobs as an astronaut I
when someone would hand me a piece of
equipment or a procedure and I would try
to break it basically not by hitting it
with a hammer but but by you know what
what kind of operational problems could
we run into because I'd much rather
figure that out on the ground when we
can actually work with the engineers and
do something about it and develop
workaround procedures rather than wait
to were up in space and time is limited
and you don't want to have something
fail up there and then do not know what
to do about it
although that happens as well but the
process of having spent a lot of time on
the ground working with malfunctions and
how to deal with them it equips you
better even when something happens up in
space that you didn't expect you have
the mindset and the confidence that you
can deal with it and that's important
yeah yep and the missions then so 1985
with discovery and that was my first
mission and now was to rescue am alpha
of malfunctioning satellite no okay no
actually well first I should start the
my first flight assignment was to fly in
June of 1984 but back in the day shuttle
flights were getting cancelled all the
time equipment was failing flights would
get canceled you'd get bumped to another
flight so for for various reasons the
flight was supposed to go before
got cancelled so so that crew got put on
two-hour flight and then we got moved to
a flight in August of 1984 they had a
problem on the launch pad in in June so
they took the August flight and we got
bumped all the way to January of 1985
the satellite that we were supposed to
launch wasn't ready so we got bumped to
another flight which was supposed to go
in March of 85 they had a problem with
the shuttle we didn't launch tail April
the original purpose of that first
mission was just to take two satellites
up punch them out of the cargo bay of
the shuttle and each of them has an
upper stage which would then take them
up to geostationary orbit because they
were both communication satellites is a
four day mission and they go up punch
out the satellites and come back home
why did it require astronauts to punch
out the satellites well that's a very
interesting question and the the answer
which was determined after the
Challenger disaster was that you don't
remember that when the shuttle was
originally built it was thought that it
it could fly a lot more frequently that
it ended up being able to fly it turned
out it was a much more complex it was a
reusable vehicle but reusing it
refurbishing it turning it around took a
lot longer and was much more complicated
than people had originally hoped not
surprisingly maybe because we you know
we had never built a reusable spacecraft
before you what you would have thought
that the first reusable spacecraft would
have been a small X vehicle you know
it's a follow-on from the x-15 something
like that so that we could actually
learn something about how do you how do
you refer [ __ ] a spacecraft once it's
come back from space no the Space
Shuttle I mean it's huge it was the size
of a dc9 airplane and and you know the
fact that the idea that that this was
the first reusable this huge vehicle and
there are you know political and policy
reasons why NASA had to build the
shuttle that it did it had to satisfy
all users because the original idea was
the shuttle would replace all expendable
rockets and it was considered at the
time it was going to be it had so much
redundancy in it it was going to be in
be safe the crew would not need an
escape system first time that that was
ever done and and so yeah if you had to
launch a satellite you just put it in
the shuttle and yeah there are people
there and and so we would we would go
through the operations to deploy the the
satellites after Challenger people
realized that despite everything that
had been done to make the shuttle as
safe as possible you could still have
loss of life and so the decision was
made no there's no reason to have to
have people just to launch a satellite
so satellite launches were returned to
Expendables and and more or less we use
the shuttle for things where it made
sense to have people on board
but before Challenger and that was my
first flight was we did everything with
the shuttle so the the idea was we were
just going to go up on a relatively
short mission launch these two
satellites we had one or two medical
experiments that we were carrying out
but then come home what happened was
that the the first satellite we launched
that was fine and you know we we
launched the satellite then we get out
of the way because 45 minutes later the
engine turns on and that satellite goes
up to geostationary orbit the second
satellite we deployed out of the shuttle
and that normally is the end of our
responsibility but we looked at it for a
while and there's a little antenna on
the top which is supposed to pop up
which we had seen many times in the
simulator because we had done this many
many times for practice yes well it
never nothing happened after about five
minutes you know I turned to one of my
crewmates there something's wrong here
so I called down to Houston
the omni antenna has not popped up so
the suspicion already was you know
something is really wrong inside the
satellite they told us to move away from
it just in case the engine was gonna
fire 45 minutes later although we really
didn't expect it to fire because the
whole timing sequence never started up
that that would have popped up that
antenna so we we moved away and sure
enough it didn't fire and then they said
well don't move any further away just
and we'll think of what to do and you
know we didn't know what they were gonna
come up with and what can we do we have
we had no special tools onboard we had
no training on what what to do if the
satellite didn't work because nobody had
ever anticipated that but it did turn
out the first thing you look for when
something fails is what we call a single
point failure because if you have
redundancy it's much less likely that
that multiple things will fail in the
same way but there was one single switch
on the outside of the satellite which is
normally closed when the satellites in
the cargo bay it's part of the whole
timing sequence it's a safety measure
you you don't want the engine to fire
when it's inside the shuttle that would
be a bad thing so this switch has to
open up when when the satellite leaves
the shuttle and and the thought was
there's a little micro switch underneath
the external big part of the switch and
you know maybe it's sticky or something
and so that was really the only thing
that we had access to but they basically
had us build some special tools I mean
it was sort of like that Apollo 13
moment where they they throw all this
stuff on the table that we have on board
and they say all right got to come up
with a tool to do this and they came up
with two objects that looked kind of
like fly swatters so we became known as
the SWAT team and and then when they
were telling us all about what they were
thinking I
remember the call coming up saying
discovery Houston where we're thinking
of several different options for what we
might do one of which involves a space
walking now that magic word space walk
because for every shuttle flight two
astronauts get trained on how to use a
spacesuit and do a space walk just as a
contingency in case something happens
that would prevent the shuttle from
coming home and so I was one of those
two people and I guess we had gotten
good reports from our trainers who had
watched us training underwater and they
said you know you know you can you can
trust Jeff and Dave to they know what
they're doing and so sure enough they
had us go out and attach these tools to
the end of the robotic arm and that was
an amazing experience because I had
never I hadn't I mean you always dream
about doing a spacewalk if you're an
astronaut that's that's the the closest
you can come to really be in space you
know here's my hand here's a vacuum I
mean I you're really in space with a big
wraparound view with your helmet but
what I found was the the value of the
training because I'll never forget I
opened the hatch and sort of slid out on
my belly I was facing down to the floor
of the the shuttles cargo bay because I
had to go over to the tool box to get
the tools I needed for the job and
thinking to myself you know that the
training was really good because I felt
comfortable I knew what I was doing and
it felt really very much like when I was
in the water tank which is and the
reason we trained in the water is
because this space chute suit on on the
earth weighs about 300 pounds and and so
you can't really do anything in it but
in the water you float and and they they
balance you out with lead weights so
you're neutrally buoyant you don't float
you don't sink and and so you can
actually work in the spacesuit
underwater
it's it's as close as we can come to
actually being out in space and so I
remember thinking to myself it really
feels like when I was underwater that
was great training then after I had all
the tools I I turned around to go back
and I looked up and there was the earth
and the sky and the stars and I knew I
wasn't in the water tank anymore it was
that was an incredible thing and and we
did the job and got good good ratings
for how we moved around in a spacesuit
and and that turned out you know totally
by chance did I happen to be and you
know after four different flight
assignments to be on that flight when
that satellite happened to fail and I
got to do a spacewalk and then eight
years later when it was time to choose a
crew to go up and rescue Hubble because
the Hubble telescope repair was such a
critical mission for NASA they said only
people who have previously done
spacewalks are eligible to get a sign to
go fix Hubble and I had my union card
first basically the card this is 93 with
endeavour that's right and that was my
fourth spaceflight that was your fourth
spaceflight and and because you had your
card for going and doing his face walk
releasing a sign that's so interesting
and so crazy how back then you could get
bumped and bumped and bumped and now it
seems as though the amount of space
flights that were doing and and also not
needing crew to deploy the actual
satellite but automating that process to
potentially save lives and then also I
want you to speak even before we get to
Columbia Atlantis etc teach us about the
EDL entry descent and landing process
because yeah we've heard that it's like
cooing over the Niagara Falls in a
barrel and having that barrel be on fire
well I would think going over Niagara
Falls is well first of all it doesn't
take nearly as long
and well you would be weightless for for
part of that at least so in any case
regardless of the of the aptness of the
analogy yeah I I didn't know what to
expect the first time our commander had
been in space once before and and so he
gave us a little bit of a you know
introduction and and he he he could
actually see the G meter which would
measure the the acceleration and and he
told me because I was sitting in behind
where I couldn't actually see it he said
let me know when you think we've got up
to about one G and you'll be surprised
you know back to one earth gravity here
so anyway you turn the shuttle around
you fire the maneuvering engines to slow
you down just a little bit and that
drops the far side of your orbit you
know 45 minutes away and the other side
of the earth your orbit takes you down
into the upper reaches of the atmosphere
and so after the engines are fired you
know you're coming home you're still
weightless you're still in space but
there's nothing you you're coming home
one way or the other of course we have
to fire the engines at just the right
time so that we end up at the right
place because unlike other spacecraft
the shuttle can't land in the water it
can't land anyway it can only land in a
runway so they never bothered like with
jungle training or things like that for
us flying the shuttle because you know
if you don't land in a runway you don't
need to worry about survival training
because you're not going to survive
there were certain emergency procedures
which we did practice you know if the
the shuttle has a hard landing and you
have to evacuate things like that but
basically so anyway we're on our way
back and not too much happens what I
would do I I would take a pen or pencil
and and just let it float in front of
my face and then what you notice very
slowly it starts to move down because
you hit the very upper regions of the
atmosphere and the friction starts to
slow you down
and that decelerates the shuttle and
that's what creates the initial onset of
gravity so it gets down I'll pick it up
now it's coming down a little faster now
it's coming down much fat now I reach
over to get a mic camera to take a
picture out the window
these were heavy Nikon f4 f5
normally you just touch it with your
finger it floats up and you can just
maneuver it around go to pick it up oh
what's this you know it has weight it's
amazing how use you get to being
weightless and I want to have a plenty
of clarification point quick so this is
different this Soyuz descent oh the
shuttle is is totally different from
Sawyer Soyuz uses space capsule sole and
that's when that yeah that comes in much
steeper and much faster with a much
higher G load which is what they
normally do when they returned from the
International Space Station right now
all flights to and from the station or
on the Russian Soyuz but even once we
start getting the spacex dragon or the
boeing Starliner those are still
capsules so yeah they'll they'll have a
you know people who some of my
colleagues who have ridden the Soyuz as
well as the shuttle will tell you I mean
the shuttle is a pretty rough ride on
the way up especially the first two
minutes when you're burning the solid
boosters but it's a very smooth ride
home compared to the the Soyuz which is
particularly when the parachute opens is
a huge shock and then you're swinging
back and forth and and then when you
actually hit the ground yeah they do
fire retro rockets just before you hit
but it it really is a hard hit they tell
people you know keep your mouth closed
when you hit the ground because you
don't want to bite your tongue off I
mean it's it's that much of a shock know
the shuttle is much more civilized
different space you know with wings then
what happens is when you get down to
about 250,000 feet you you first start
picking up the atmosphere about four
hundred thousand feet two hundred and
fifty thousand feet is when you really
start to heat up
and that's when looking out the back
window of the shuttle which act you're
looking into the wake just it's just
like a motorboat leaves a wake behind it
you know the entering spacecraft leave
it leaves a hypersonic weight which is
glowing at thousands of degrees and
having to have a heat shield
well that's without that I mean the
shuttle is made of aluminum the body in
which which melts at you know less than
a thousand degrees and and you've got
temperatures of many thousands of
degrees out there and so the optimal
material is for the heat shield well the
heat shield for all previous spacecraft
had been expendable it was a what we
call an ablative material which
gradually melted it was kind of a
phenolic resin embedded in a honeycomb
and and as it heated up it would melt
and that would take the heat away but it
was a one shot only and it was rather
heavy so it was a big challenge for the
shuttle devising a reusable and very
light heat shield and that's what all
those ceramic tiles you know they have
like upwards of thirty thousand tiles on
the shuttle and they have to be really
light but very very good insulators and
and it was an amazing development to
build those tiles getting them to stick
onto the shuttle turned out to be harder
than people had imagined but that was a
whole nother story they'd finally did
figure that out and it works it works so
post 250 thousand feet though yeah so I
mean I was just mesmerized by this light
show going on and you know the the
shimmering lines of the wake and between
each of the tiles they have these little
gap fillers and every once in a while a
tiny piece of that would come off and so
you'd be looking at the reentry wake and
every once in a while you get these
little flashes of light you know
zing and every time I saw one of those I
would I would think to myself wow I hope
that wasn't anything important and it
was you know we got to the ground and
and then you know I was I was feeling
really heavy so I I told the commander
he but we must be up at 1g now right so
yeah we're about a third of a G you know
because after being used to
weightlessness for we have been up for a
whole week as it turned out gravity it
affects you much more strongly up for a
week in zero-g right and then yeah you
your body gets used to that yeah elegy
changed well I wasn't physically you
know in one week your body doesn't
change that much for people spending six
months in the space station they they
have to be very concerned about changes
in their body they have to exercise
regularly
we had a treadmill on board and
everybody else ran on the treadmill so I
figured well I better try it out so in
order to be able to run on a treadmill
you you have to put on a body harness
with bungee cords to hold him down
so that you can run so you know I ran
for about 20 minutes and then as I
release the bungee cords and floated
back up I realized you know while I was
running on the treadmill I felt like I
was back on earth I don't need that I'm
gonna be on earth for the rest of my
life I want to be in space and so that's
the last time I ever exercised in space
which for a week or two I mean you can
go without you can lie in bed for two
weeks and and you're not going to suffer
any undue harm but for six months yeah
you have to exercise no question and and
they spend two to three hours a day up
in the space station exercising I didn't
yeah but there's still when you when you
get back into a gravity field strange
things happen I mean right after we
landed can you teach us about the
landing process of listening and then
you finally come well what what happens
that that heating phase where you you
see this in
that's way behind you that lasts for
about ten minutes and and then by that
time you're you're pretty much up to 1g
and and now the the other incredible
thing then was we were landing in
Florida so as we came over the shuttle
the the the California coast one of the
things when you're in orbit and you look
at the earth going by you it moves at
about the same rate as the earth when
you're looking out of it an airplane
window you know you're going a lot
faster but you're much further away you
don't really have any sense of speed
because you know there's no vibration
there's no wind
there's no billboards rushing by you
coming over the coast of California
though you know now we're we're down you
know many times closer to the earth than
we were when we were in orbit so now the
ground is really screaming by and and
that's when I first got the sensation of
speed was crossing the California coast
and then we basically maneuver it's all
about energy management you want to get
to the runway with a little bit of extra
energy just so that you you don't want
to get there with too little energy it's
much easier to bleed off the energy
so you basically fly over and then when
you get right over the landing field you
you do a big circle heading alignment
circle they call it you line up with a
runway and then when you finally go
subsonic and you you you by the way you
have those two booms and you can feel a
little shock as you as you're going down
lower than the speed of sound and then
the pilot takes over manually this is
what the pilots have been training to do
hundreds of times in the shuttle
training aircraft and in the simulators
and then they line up with the runway
and they
of course it's a glider so you only get
one shot at landing but that's what they
trained for and we had a great landing
only problem with our landing that time
there was a there was a big crosswind
and the shuttle was designed so that the
nosewheel could steer which is how you
keep in the center even if there's a
crosswind but there was a problem with
the redundancy problem and the potential
single point failure which could turn
the wheel over hard which would be very
bad so in those early days the pilots
weren't using the nosewheel steering the
way to steer the shuttle and the runway
would be differential pressure on the
brakes on the rear tires we had a strong
crosswind so our commander had to
continually use one brake and and we had
the the original brakes at the time they
they were subsequently improved anyway
the net result it overheated led to a
blowout it's the only tire blowout we
ever had this was my first flight we had
gone through all this incredible stuff
with the satellite failure an
unscheduled spacewalk the first time
NASA had ever done an unscheduled
unplanned spacewalk in its entire
history a rendezvous in space with the
satellite and you know I felt us
touching down on the runway you could
feel the deceleration the nosewheel
comes down gradually you know we were
coming to a stop we were just about
stopped and I remember thinking to
myself wow what an incredible week us
mission all these things we did but now
it's over nothing can go wrong and
everything you know I thought one of the
fuel tanks had blown up or something it
was the tire at blown yeah and luckily
we were just about stopped so there was
no adverse effect so we if that had
happened at a high speed you could have
run off the runway what was the speed at
landing speed at landing is about two
hundred and fifty miles an hour so much
much faster than a normal air
interesting that you can slow it down
from orbiting at
wouldn't and whatever speed it well this
the they're slowing down from 18,000
miles an hour in orbit is all due to the
friction of the atmosphere we slow it
down just a few hundred miles an hour
with with the engine firing but that
lowers our orbit enough so that we hit
the atmosphere and then the atmosphere
if the earth didn't have an atmosphere
like if we were landing on the moon all
that slowing down has to be done with
rocket propellant which we don't have
that much propellant so we can do house
in mouth burn down to 250 all by using
almost all by using just the atmosphere
in this and of course that kinetic
energy is transformed into heat energy
yeah and so then I want it we'll get to
the other mission just quickly want to
know about the we're not using shuttles
technology anymore all right well we're
certainly we're not in the new vehicles
most of them with one exception our
capsules stayin absol right Sierra
Nevada company is building a winged
vehicle a much smaller vehicle than the
space shuttle and they hopefully will be
testifying it in the next year or two so
the two are either capsule vehicles
which is on the booster or as well as
the winged vehicle which is attached to
the boost
well actually the Sierra Nevada it's
called The Dream Chaser and and that's
small enough that it can actually sit on
top of the rocket which is where a
spacecraft ought to be I mean that's
it's we're devoted the shuttle was so
big it had to be on the side and that
made it vulnerable to the the foam
falling off and hitting the tiles which
is what eventually led to the Columbia
disaster oh and that's we know that
that's what oh yeah yeah Wow yeah okay
interesting so now always on top of the
rocket and interesting capsule versus
that wing technology okay so then to the
the Columbia deployed a UV astronomy
laboratory asses Astro one was the
deployment NASA signed up to with the
European Space Agency to have the
European Space Agency create the Space
Lab and there were two aspects of space
lab there was a module in the Space Lab
which is what most people think of which
you could put experiments in and and it
had special computers and and that was
used for a lot of scientific missions
but the Europeans also built a pointing
system for telescopes which could be
mounted outside in the shuttle cargo bay
and you could do ultraviolet or x-ray
astronomy things where you have to be
above the atmosphere and as an
astronomer I got assigned to the first
ultraviolet astronomy mission actually
another astronomy colleague who had also
gone to Amherst College so we had to
Amherst astronomers on the shuttle and
two non astronaut we called them payload
specialists but they were scientists
astronomers who had worked on the
telescope's that we were carrying up and
so we flew them so we had four PhD
astronomers on that flight we were
scheduled I actually was assigned to
that flight before my first flight went
so I knew already went during my first
flight what my second flight would be
and we were assigned to fly in March of
1986 in conjunction with Halley's Comet
because we wanted to get ultraviolet
observations of the comet so we would
have been the very next flight after the
Challenger disaster so we were very
close to that crew we knew them well it
was a I was in the simulator that day
the last nine minutes we come out of the
simulator to watch the launch on TV and
of course we saw the explosion the
disaster and we didn't go back to the
simulator that day but early on we
didn't know what the problem was
obviously there were a few people who
already knew about the
the o-ring seals but we didn't possibly
it I mean it was a terrible disaster but
possibly whatever the problem was could
be fixed relatively quickly and so they
NASA told us to continue our training
and that was really strange the next day
we had to go in for an asset simulation
after having watched the Challenger
disintegrate the day before and so we I
remember we told the simulator crew hey
how about not giving us any malfunctions
let us have a clean run to orbit and and
so we did but we trained for I don't
remember a week two weeks but and and
then it became apparent that this was a
serious problem and we were going to be
standing down for a couple of years and
so we stopped training and in fact we
didn't fly that mission until 1990 yeah
in the disaster was again 80 the
disaster was was the end of January of
86 86 yeah how was the Challenger next
flight I mean we would have flown or
four years later no it was in 88 88 was
that it was about two and a half years
Wow yeah well they had to completely not
only did they redesign the solid booster
seals but they then went deep into the
design of all of the shuttle systems and
they found a lot of other potential
failures many of which were corrected so
the shuttle when it flew again in 1988
was much safer than it was that was
probably the safest flight of the that
the shuttle ever made because at that
point if anybody could think of anything
that needed attention they would get
management's ear unfortunately as time
goes on
you get used to success and we had you
know many years of successful shuttle
flights and people and start taking
safety for granted and that that's
recipe for disaster and unfortunately
that's exactly what happened with
Columbia where people had seen the foam
falling off for many flights but it
never really did any serious damage to
the shuttle and so you sort of get used
to it and you so yeah foam falls off
don't worry it's happened before until
it you get a bad luck and the big piece
makes a big hole in your wing which
nobody knew about and we lost the crew
and just to take a moment to you know be
with how much with them and how much
work and hard work they put into pushing
the boundaries of the edge of what we
knew and how hard they worked and we're
really grateful for them to be able to
do that yeah it was it was very painful
for for everybody not just for the
astronauts I mean everyone in Mission
Control and the people in Florida who
prepare the shuttles for flight I mean
amazing group of people they I mean the
the shuttles for them were like living
breathing objects I mean they had a
personal relationship and yeah they were
devastated that the crew had been lost
but but they were also devastated that
they had lost their vehicles you know
that they had grown up with and worked
with for so many years and then so
teachers on in 1990 when you go up with
Columbia to ask for 1uv
yeah well the the first flight of the
Astro payload we we had a lot of
problems on that mission there are two
computers special Space Lab computers
which control the operation of the
telescope's and the very first day of
the mission one of them burn
up not a nice feeling to wake up in the
morning and smell smoke on a spacecraft
and then on the fourth day and well we
could keep operating with just one
computer then on the fourth day of what
was supposed to be what was a nine-day
mission the second computer burned up
well what they discovered was we didn't
know this until after we got back but
during all that time the four years that
had been sitting on the ground
periodically they would turn the system
long and all the computers are
air-cooled and the air comes through a
filter because you don't want dust
coming in and nobody had thought to
clean the filters they were full of dust
and so we weren't getting proper airflow
over the computers and so the computer
is overheated and that's one of the
problems when you're in weightlessness
there's no convective cooling because
hot air doesn't rise and so you have to
blow air across the computer with a fan
and if you don't have enough air intake
it overheats and and luckily together
with Mission Control we figured out a
way to continue the mission so we we did
get some useful science out of it but it
was very frustrating yeah and then the
Atlantis mission this was with European
retrievable carrier Eureka mm-hmm yeah
this is a great acronym and the tethered
satellite system TSS when I was with
NASA and the Italian space agency and
this is 1992 with Atlantis so your
Eureka was designed to be a reusable
satellite where you could put
experiments on it we deployed it using
the robotic arm and just left it in
orbit and a few years later another
shuttle went up and brought it back but
the most complex experiment we had was
the tethered satellite which is in the
concept of that is that you you deploy a
satellite from the shuttle but rather
than just let it go free in space it
remains attached to the shuttle by a fin
electrically conductive cable that's 20
kilometres long that's about 12 and a
half miles we would deploy it all the
way
as this conductive wire moves through
the Earth's magnetic field it acts like
an electric generator and so it
generates up to about 4000 volts and
using that you can vary the voltage on
the satellite by by controlling how much
current flows through the tether and
that would allow us we had a lot of
plasma diagnostic instruments on the
satellite which would study the
interaction of the satellite with the
Earth's plasma in the ionosphere
fascinating fascinating experiment both
the plasma science and the dynamics of
the tether yeah which I could spend
hours talking about that but we spent a
lot of and and the fascinating thing
nobody had ever flown a tethered
satellite and so we had to from scratch
develop the procedures the people who
originally designed the tether satellite
I think they thought it was all gonna be
all automatic that you just push a
button and the satellite would go up our
job as astronauts figure out what might
go wrong and the more we studied it the
more potential problems we came up with
all of which required manual
intervention so we had to argue strongly
over the years to get more and more
manual control and and and in the end we
got what we needed it was a very
frustrating project on that flight we
got the satellite out to about 200
meters and then it jammed and they tried
to restart it several times it was
getting out of control at one point one
thing you don't want is for the thing to
wrap all the way around the shuttle and
and so at one point you know we were
trying to control the Jets on the
satellite because it had gone over to
about 45-degree angle if it had gone
just a little bit more I was gonna have
to cut the tether yeah push a button and
the shuttle commander was trying to fly
the shuttle
get back underneath and we were trying
to push the satellite I mean it was
pretty hairy in the end after several
attempts and it kept getting jammed we
decided together with Mission Control
you know we don't know what's happening
and we just pulled it back and actually
when they first tried to pull it back it
wouldn't come back gotten jammed in both
directions and they had to start
preparing for another contingency
spacewalk I was going to get a bad
reputation there every time often goes
up something goes wrong but in the end
they maybe I should say unfortunately
from our point of view but they figured
out a way to overcome the jam without us
going out and doing a spacewalk so we
did get the satellite back and weary
flew it again on my fifth and final
shuttle flight where we did get it out
almost all the way to 20 kilometers and
then again tragically there was a short
circuit and Sparks and it melted the
tether and the whole thing broke and the
satellite was lost so very frustrating
but fascinating project I'm yeah
hopefully another tethered satellite
system at some well there's a lot of
fascinating things you can do with
tethers which is why the initial
interest in it and I'm sure someday the
technology will come back and be a fuse
but you know right now we don't have a
shuttle and and that there have been
some unmanned robotic tethered satellite
missions and there's there's still quite
a bit of interest in tethers but I don't
think NASA at the moment has any plans
to do anything with it and then the
fourth flight on endeavour you captured
service and restored to full capacity to
Hubble telescope right now that
certainly was the most significant and
exciting of all the things that I've
done in space I mean both as an
astronomer and an astronaut to put my
two hands on the the greatest telescope
in the world up in space I mean what a
what a thrill but you know we had lived
through all the build-up to the launch
of the Hubble Space Telescope it was it
was really very gratifying to the
astronomy commune
- to NASA a lot of publicity before
Hubble was going to be put in orbit
about the incredible new view of the
universe we were gonna get the public
was was into it I mean there's a lot of
lot of interest and so you know the
shock when my god this billion dollar
telescope can't focus properly and how
long did it take until the first
malfunction
well the telescope was put in to orbit
in the spring of 1990 and the what you
do with a new telescope on the ground or
in space it's like you pick up a pair of
binoculars I mean you take the focus
will you go back and forth you're trying
to find the sweet spot where everything
is in focus and that's what you do with
the new telescope and and so I I don't
remember exactly but it was it was weeks
maybe a little a month or so but it was
during that summer of 1990 that it
dawned on the astronomers who were
trying to get it in focus that oh my god
it doesn't focus it had I mean the the
images were classically what what's
called spherical aberration which which
is when the the mirror it turns out I
mean they were so well first of all it
was a it was an absolute disaster I mean
Hubble became the butt of jokes of
late-night comedians it was denounced on
the halls of the US Congress as a techno
Turkey I mean it was NASA at the time
was trying to convince Congress to start
the initial funding for what would
eventually become the International
Space Station yeah of course NASA was
not very popular in Congress and the
basic message was you know go do
something about Hubble and then talk to
us about the station and and so it was
an absolutely critical mission yes
and III remember getting back from my
third spaceflight that was actually the
only time I came back from a spaceflight
without knowing what my next flight
would be because I had been assigned to
the tethered satellite before Astro
One Flew because of the delay in Astro
one I had started already before 1990
when Astro flew I had already started
working on the tethered satellite so I
knew I was going to be on that mission
but after tared satellite I didn't know
what my fourth flight if anything was
gonna be I think my wife thought I was
gonna retire finally from her pocket a
few she had liked my space flights
because of the danger involved which is
understandable but it's like three years
though to send you up to make the fix on
Hubble well it was actually I came back
in August of 92 from the tethered
satellite mission okay
people had been working on what to do
about Hubble you know because the first
thing they had to figure out what the
problem was they they figured out it
turns out the the measuring device which
you use when you're actually grinding
the mirror had been installed
incorrectly a long story that I can't go
into all the details but but that's what
led to the mirror being slightly too
flat they took about one micron too much
glass off the outside of the mirror one
micron one millionth of a meter that's
one fiftieth the diameter of a human
hair
but Hubble's optics are so precise that
that made all the difference anyway once
once they understood that then optical
engineers astronomers mechanical
engineers figured out a fix for each of
the observing instruments you have to
install two tiny mirrors each of them
about the size of your thumbnail one of
them you have the out-of-focus light
coming in that's normally there each
camera has a little 45 degree mirror the
out-of-focus light bounces into the
camera well we have to put one mirror to
block the out-of-focus light bounce it
off another mirror which is slightly
curved to compensate for the lack of
curvature in the main mayor and then
that light gets reflected into the
observing instrument
that was the correct all of those things
and and you know there were about two
dozen of these little mirrors that had
to be infertile 24 well what they what
they did was I mean it's not just
challenging for the optical engineers
but then the mechanical engineers had to
figure out how to package all these
things in one big box yes and they all
had to be folded up because you couldn't
have them all deployed we'd never be
able to put it into the telescope
luckily Hubble was designed from the
very beginning to be serviced by
astronauts so you could take out an old
instrument and that left a big hole in
the telescope where we could put this
big box with all these folded mirrors
inside the interesting once it was
inside then automatic automated but the
whole thing comes out and opens up like
an umbrella more than firend and all the
mirrors end up in the right place often
say so you could you could it was no
compartmentalized it's exactly that
that's the way Hubble was designed great
design it absolutely was I mean it was
designed for servicing and it was it was
unique and huge and we really showed the
value of it you know Hubble would have
been a billion-dollar piece of space
junk yeah and we wouldn't have these
gorgeous photos of the cosmos yeah and
of course because there was so much
publicity to the problems that Hubble
had there was incredible interest in
this rescue mission so much so I was
told later on by people in the media
that more people watched our Hubble
rescue mission than any other
spaceflight other than Apollo 11 yeah
and and that's awesome yeah so awesome
so then you went out with with another
astronaut to go this repair this mission
was so calm it was most complex shuttle
mission that had ever been anticipated
well there were so many there were so
many things that had to it wasn't just
the optics the the solar panels had to
be replay
a bunch of electronic boxes had to be
ripped there were there were a dozen
different things that that we had to do
so it was gonna require five spacewalks
which had never been done before oh you
had to go out and come back in five
different days of spacewalk during days
and why it was the reason why because it
took you multiple hours to defer oh it
takes time to do these things out there
yeah I mean we couldn't and a spacesuit
you can only stay out for about a little
over eight hours maximum we try to plan
spacewalks for about six and a half
hours so that you have a little bit of
you know time built in in case their
problems and which we had and what's the
max for six and half why why well you
run out of electrical power probably
goes first
oxygen yeah yeah and those tethers that
the space suits tethered to the we are
always attached by a stainless steel
wire yeah to the shuttle yes so that it
doesn't have like an oxygen run to it no
no it's just a stainless whatever
everything is contained in the backpack
Wow yeah so it was felt normally you
only send up two people to do spacewalks
on a shuttle mission but we had five
days in a row and it was felt that might
be a little much for just two people so
we had four space walkers and we went
out in alternate days so my partner and
I went out on days one three and five
and the other two went out on days two
and four Wow and we we cross trained on
all the tasks just in case someone was
incapacitated and as it turned out we
all did our proper spacewalks but it all
work and it all worked our we what we
first of all we had to rendezvous with
Hubble how did you use around it well
you know rendezvous was we had done a
lot of rendezvous at that point I mean
rendezvous was developed first back in
the Gemini program because they had to
do rendevouz on Apollo and you know
basically the the critical thing for a
rendezvous a satellite is in a certain
orbit so the telescope's in orbit you're
on the earth and the launch pad and the
earth is rotating or
and you have to launch right when you're
underneath Hubble's orbit because once
you're in space changing your orbit
takes a lot of propellant which we don't
have so so we had to law and and that
determines your launch time which for
December 2nd 1993 happened to be 4
o'clock in the morning which a lot of my
friends said you know why couldn't you
launch it at a decent time of day but
it's celestial mechanics beautiful you
don't get a choice so you know I
remember one of my brothers who was kind
of a space nut he said you know a little
less than 1/2 hour before your launch we
saw Hubble fly over which gave us a good
feeling like NASA must know what they're
doing here anyway so yeah you launch and
you launch so that you're slightly
behind the object you're going to
rendezvous with and so you're in a
faster orbit so you gradually catch up
to it and then you do burns and and your
burns are guided initially from the
ground and then on board we have a radar
and once we get radar lock our onboard
computer tells us when to burn and
gradually and it's really exciting you
know you first see this thing is a just
a point of light and then it gets
brighter and brighter and then finally
looking through binoculars you can start
to see the shape and Wow and then it
gets and then in the end when you get
really close I mean it's 50 feet from
top to bottom so it's it's big I mean
how do you and then what you have to do
then it's up to the the commander flying
manually to essentially know out all of
the relative motion so now we're flying
together at 18,000 miles an hour but it
it just looks like it's floating
motionless above the cargo bay and now
the robotic arm operator has to reach
out and grab it without disturbing it
and which he's well trained you did it
perfectly and then we latch it down onto
the
the work stand which then allows us to
rotate it and tilt it over so we have
access to it so it was in and so that
was the first thing I remember when they
come in after we grabbed it with the arm
and the commander could call down and
say you know happy to report we have a
good handshake with mr. Hubble's
telescope you know but that was only the
beginning then we had the five
spacewalks to do yes and so my partner
and I went out on the first day we had
to replace the gyroscopes which had
failed and that's there a high failure
item on Hubble they've they've since
kind of figured out what it was and the
the new gyroscopes that are in there now
because they've been replaced several
times hopefully aren't going to fail but
in any case we replace them that was the
very first task that we had to do and
all I had to do now was to close these
big doors and get on to the rest of the
work question how many more service
missions have there been - there had
been a total of five so for after hours
interesting and on each iteration for 20
years
well there about 30 years Wow yeah and
and and the thing about servicing you
know most people when they you asked
what's the value of servicing well they
were able to fix the optics and so they
look at it as if something breaks you
can fix it but that's not really the
most important value of servicing the
real value is that every time we visited
Hubble we put in a new more powerful
observing instrument because the
technology of detectors is continually
improving it's like Moore's law forever
computer memory zapping you want to keep
updating it Hubble was launched with
1970s detector technology after the
fifth and final servicing mission in
about ten years ago
it now has 21st century detectors and
it's almost a thousand times more
sensitive than when it was launched yes
that's the real value of servicing
that's a
it's a beautiful way to put it yeah the
servicing of the very expensive
satellite and that's what we do in the
ground I mean you build a telescope on
the ground the mirror is good for
decades you know centuries even but the
detectors that you put at the focal
plane are continually improving up until
Hubble we didn't have the ability to do
that in space and now we do yes yes so
despite the this Hubble rescue mission
being the most complex mission and that
we had ever done with the shuttle and
there were many people who thought that
it was too difficult that NASA had bit
off more than then they could chew so to
speak but we did it and so we knew after
the fifth day of space walking that we
had done everything that they asked us
to do it and fixed all the things that
were broken we had installed the new
optics and we came home and everybody
was happy lots of celebrations but you
can't turn on the instruments for a
couple of weeks because the new
instruments that we had put in a little
bit of Earth's atmosphere sticks to the
surface and you have to wait you you
can't turn on the high voltage until all
that gas has escaped because otherwise
you'll get high voltage discharge and
you'll boil your electronics so we
didn't know if all of those optics were
really going to work obviously we we
thought they would we hoped they would
but the proof is when you get the first
images down and they couldn't turn it on
you know we got back in the middle of
December and they couldn't really turn
it on until right before New Year's and
I'll never forget New Year's Eve
1993 to 1994 it was like 1 o'clock in
the morning I was cleaning up we had had
some people over phone ringing yeah so
it was an old astronomer friend who was
working at the Hubble Space Telescope
Science Institute that's where they
operate Hubble and and he you know we
wished each other happy new year he said
you know you got any champagne handy
well yeah we had a half a bottle still
in the refrigerator and go pour yourself
a glass I'm not supposed to tell anybody
this but because it's going to be
announced
publicly in a couple of days after the
holiday but we figured that somebody on
the crew ought to know that we've just
got the first pictures back from Hubble
and it works and that was I'll never
forget that moment I mean and that's
when you know history was made was made
it's right it was and Hubble has gone on
partly because of servicing to be NASA's
most productive science mission ever in
terms of the number of papers published
PhD theses and incredible groundbreaking
new discoveries I mean the the fact that
the universal expansion is accelerating
and that we have this dark energy which
is 75% of the universe and we have no
clue what it is I mean it's incredible
it's it's exciting times in astronomy
partly due to Hubble yeah yeah that's
like you said most successful NASA
project and that's that's so beautiful
how many decades and hours and lives
were put into to making the successful
project and hopefully inspiring a lot of
young people to get involved in Space
Sciences with Columbia in 1986 that was
you like you said earlier the reef light
of the tethered satellite system and
also the the third flight of the United
States microgravity payload and this was
interesting the the tethered satellite
we did get deployed and and
unfortunately it broke it did have an
interesting effect though that the this
20 kilometer long tether it reflected
light if the outside was was a white and
it actually stayed in a straight line
moving around the earth it eventually
after about three weeks it deorbited
because of the atmospheric friction but
for those three weeks you know normally
when you see a satellite flyover you see
a point of light well this you can
actually see a line moving through space
there were so many UFO reports during
those three weeks and and we actually
when we were still up in orbit we
saw that fly over a couple of times and
it's spooky to see a you know a luminous
line move through the sky like a
satellite but anyway that was the end of
the tether satellite and and but now we
we had these crystals to grow but it was
an automated experiment out on the cargo
bay however in order to grow the
crystals properly they they want to
reduce the any vibrations in the shuttle
so this experiment was originally
designed to be operated only when the
crew is asleep so that we wouldn't be
moving around well because of the
tethered satellite we were a to shift
mission because we had to be up 24 hours
a day when the satellite was deployed
and and so somebody was always awake so
the the microgravity experimenters they
were pretty upset they said do you think
you know they're gonna be moving around
and so I said look it's gonna be done on
our shift give us the readout on our
computer of the accelerometers and we
will sort of like biofeedback we will
train ourselves we we will not make any
vibrations we won't bounce off the walls
they didn't schedule any other
activities for us so for about five days
for eight hours a day
we had these quiescent periods where the
only thing that we could do was to sort
of float and look out the window and
watch the Earth's go by it was like
being a space tourist it was incredible
you know there I was up there and I
wasn't allowed to do any any work it was
it was incredible fun and they got some
good results out of it as well and teach
us about the this the images of you when
you're out repairing the Hubble or where
you're where you're out doing the
spacewalks you know you gave that
profound example of when it was you and
then the vacuum of space in your hand
teach us about when you're looking at
earth and it's what do you feel when
you're feeling this overview effect
it's the sense of the earth as a planet
what what I very strongly and and I
think a lot of my colleagues have
expressed the same feeling we're in an
incredibly hostile environment I mean
space is totally intolerant of human
error mechanical failures and that's
most of the universe is like that it's
very hostile to life and so we look down
at our home planet which is the one
place in our solar system that we know
can support life and and it becomes an
almost miraculous maybe not in a
biblical sense that depends on you know
your own philosophical background but in
any case it's a it's a unique and
wonderful place and and so I think many
astronauts actually come back with much
more of an ecological sensitivity than
when they went up just because of this
experience of you know the this the
sense of all that at life and and the
earth can it was the home of life and it
supports life and and you know we need
to take care of it yeah yeah and then
you spent four years as NASA's European
representative in Paris and then you
were also inducted into the Hall of Fame
in the astronaut Hall of Fame in 2007
and I know we we have some time to
unpack this a little bit and I know we
need to get going but hopefully we can
continue on another conversation soon
but give us the cliff notes on the
European representation in Paris and
then that theme yes my last three
flights the two tethered satellite
flights and the Hubble mission they they
all had European involvement the
Italians made the tethered satellite the
European Space Agency financed a good
part of the Hubble telescope and
provided the solar arrays anyway I spent
a lot of time in Europe NASA ever since
the 60s has had a permanent
representative in Europe working out of
the embassy in Paris the European Space
Agency headquarters is in Paris
because we have so much scientific
cooperation with the Europeans NASA from
the very beginning although NASA was
putting up satellites the Europeans at
the time couldn't put up their own
satellites now they can but but NASA
wanted the best science from all the
world and so they competitively would
open up space on u.s. satellites to you
to foreign experiments and there were so
many coming from Europe that
particularly back in the 60s when we
didn't have email and you know so much
easy communication it was it was
considered wise to have somebody on the
ground there and that's continued
obviously our communication is a lot
better but still it's like diplomacy you
want to get to know the people in Europe
who are active in the space arena you
want to get to talk with people in
European governments you know what's
happening with space policy what
possibilities are there for cooperation
between Europe and NASA I got to know
the the guy who was the European
representative when I was spending all
that time over there and and he told me
that he was getting ready to come back
to the States and I thought you know
this would be interesting so I applied
for the job well I got back from the
fifth mission where we had flown the
tethered satellite done these
microgravity crystal growing experiments
not knowing what I was going to do but
hoping that maybe I would get the the
European job well the head of the
Johnson Space Center told me right after
I got back he said you know Jeff we got
another flight for you we need the space
Walker trained astronauts because we're
gonna start building the space station
soon afterwards I found out that I had
actually been selected for the European
job so now they gave me a choice there's
all right Jeff you got to choose Paris
or space I thought about it got a little
help from my wife that you can imagine
but you know I I was not tired of
spaceflight I mean I I would go up again
minute if I had the opportunity and and
I would have loved to have had another
space flight and spend four years in
Paris but that was not an option so we
chose Paris and I have no regrets I had
five wonderful flights with incredible
yes you know incredible experiences and
we had four incredible years in in Paris
I really got to know the European space
scene and in addition it was you know
wonderful living in a beautiful
apartment at government expense thanks
to all the US tax payers yes yes and and
and I think I was appreciated for being
able to because of my my astronaut
background I in addition to working with
space people over there and and the fact
that I my French was pretty good and I
can speak German and Spanish Italian so
I did a lot of public relations TV shows
radio call-in sent that's a challenge in
a foreign language yet yeah but yeah we
had great four years and I had actually
maintained certain contacts at MIT all
the time I was at NASA I came back on a
few occasions and gave talks and the the
department had in aeronautics and
Astronautics
had the idea that you know we do a lot
of work designing space systems it might
be a nice idea to have someone who
really knows what it's like working up
there and so they offered me a chance to
come back to MIT and so Here I am
finally as a professor after all these
years my wife you know she kids me you
know most people they go into an
academic career and within 7 years
they're a tenured professor why did it
take you 30 30 years but I punished no
complaints but I'm really happy here I
mean I one of the one of the things that
I was really concerned about leaving
NASA
was not being connected with the space
program anymore and one of the wonderful
things in our department here at MIT
we're very closely connected we do a lot
of work with NASA with the Air Force
with DARPA and and so I've had a great
opportunity to continue my involvement
with with space right up to now and and
you know now I've got a really exciting
experiment I'm the deputy principal
investigator of an experiment which is
going to go to Mars on the next big
Rover which is going to be launched in
the summer of 2020 yes and this is the
moxie experiment moxie is an acronym
which stands for Mars oxygen is ru and
that's a nested acronym in situ resource
utilization experiment Mars oxygen is
our you experiment moxie and is are you
in situ resource utilization basically
means learning to live off the land
which since time immemorial explorers
have had to do that I mean you're
sailing across the ocean you come across
an island somewhere well what do you do
you put on on shore you you look for
fresh water for food we haven't done
that in space the astronauts went to the
moon they took everything they needed
with them but they are they were only
staying for three days you go to Mars
and you have a lot of requirements among
other things for oxygen not only to
breathe but assuming that you want to
come back home you're probably going to
need many tens of tons of oxygen just to
launch your Mars ascent vehicle to get
off the surface of Mars back to Mars
orbit so you can get your ride home
bringing 30 tons of dumb old oxygen all
the way from the earth you know it takes
15 tons of propellant in Earth orbit to
bring one ton of anything to the surface
of Mars so to bring 30 tons of dumb old
oxygen to the surface
of Mars we would need to launch 450 tons
of propellant from the surface of the
earth that's expensive now some things
that are going to go to the surface of
Mars we have to launch from the earth
you know complex habitats
you know the rocket to get up but the
fuel for the rocket the propellant man
if we could make the oxygen on Mars
we're way ahead of the game and that's
exactly what our experiment is going to
demonstrate for the very first time it's
a process which has been developed and
demonstrated here on earth but if you're
going to rely on it for something
critical like you know that's your ride
home from the surface of Mars
you better demonstrate it to just make
sure that Mars doesn't have any nasty
surprises and that's what we're gonna do
so we're gonna it's a small-scale
experiment only about yay big and it's
only going to make about 10 grams an
hour compared to for a real human
mission you'd have to make about 2
kilograms an hour so you know half a
percent scale but nevertheless we'll
demonstrate the process I was an
astronaut I was lucky I had five space
flights but I'm never gonna get to Mars
myself I don't imagine but it's nice to
be able to send an experiment there that
someday will help humans when we finally
do get our act together and get to Mars
yeah and this is these are the these are
the the components to what the
Millennials and the gen Z and onward
will be able to go to Mars with the
levels of efficiency that we need to
sustain and make a consciousness
interplanetary something that I thought
was super interesting about that so when
we get to summer 2020 is when the Mars
rover gets launched there's only a
twenty six month window for the
rendezvous of Earth and Mars and then we
arrive in February 20 21 and then Mars
is atmosphere is 96% co2 that is how we
make oxygen it's a very thin atmosphere
but we we suck the atmosphere
we compress it and then we put it into
an electrolysis unit you know highschool
chemistry you put these two electrodes
into a beaker of water you hook it up to
a battery and Wow hydrogen bubbles up
one side oxygen bubbles the other side
you're electrically decomposing water
you can do that with carbon dioxide it's
a lot more difficult you have to heat it
up to 800 Celsius you have to run it
over catalytic beds you need it
reinstate Eliza's or Coney and
electrolyte but nevertheless you can do
it and we've done it in the laboratory
here on earth and we just have to
demonstrate that it all works on Mars
and let's talk on a geopolitical level
what do you how do you feel about the
future of the space economy balancing
out competition but cooperation how do
you think we can best well we're in a
new era now particularly in this country
because previously it was only
governments that could launch things
into space and and bring back humans
from space now we have private companies
in the US and and now also in China
they're starting up with with private
space companies so we now have in
addition to the Orion space capsule that
NASA is developing we have four
different human carriers all developed
by different companies we have rockets
which can now land the first stage of
the rocket and recover them space
exploration I mean this is Flash Gordon
kind of stuff that's it back in the 50s
when I was a little kid flash Gordon's
rockets landed vertically but nobody
ever thought we'd do that for real and
now we're doing it so it's exciting
times I mean we we have a tremendous
amount of innovation going on which
would not have occurred if it were just
the government I mean there's no
question the international competition
is what got the Space Age going the the
race to the moon between the US and the
Soviet Union you know we never would
have gotten to the moon without that
because of the incredible
investment that our country had to make
which was done because it was part of
the Cold War we learned a tremendous
amount of scientifically and it was
incredibly inspirational for so many
people but it was the competition that
got us there now we've got a lot of
commercial competition yeah you know
SpaceX has figured out how to
drastically reduce the cost of launching
satellites and the other satellite
launchers are really feeling the pinch
even the Chinese complained they said
this is unfair competition you know he
must be getting some sort of subsidies
or whatever man if the Chinese are
complaining that you're undercutting
them in price you must be doing
something right yeah yeah the now with
the ability to be able to go and take
the next steps in the space economy I
think the creativity of what we can do
is just about to be unlocked at
unprecedented levels it's going to be
very exciting we need the dreamers and
creators to actually be the executors
and to make the blend of academia and
Industry and government and
geopolitically come together in a
powerful way
just a couple last thoughts on a
governance level I'm very interested to
hear your thoughts on this what would be
your ideal way to govern Mars well until
you get a large number of people I think
it will be run on a mission oriented
basis which means you pretty much have a
quasi-military type hierarchy where you
have a commander of a mission and you
know that's that's the way we run
missions up to now you know every
mission is that a commander we have a
commander on the space station the early
settlements of Mars the missions they'll
they'll have a command structure I don't
know what the minimum number of people
is before you actually are going to get
people interested in in self-government
you know we would hope that our Western
principles of democracy would be adapted
on Mars but you know the Chinese are in
the business too and and and they have
different ideas about how to organize
governments and I I don't really know
certainly experience with the early
colonies in the u.s. was such that you
you couldn't just have freewheeling
democracy where anybody could do what
they wanted because your survival
depended on working as part of a group
so there's no question you're going to
be in a very hostile environment and
there will be certain limitations on
individual freedom and ability to I mean
you could just can't just open the
airlock and go out for a walk anytime
you feel like it because you're using up
valuable resources or that it belonged
to everybody so you know the question of
you know what are the Commons and how do
you protect these avoiding the so-called
tragedy of the Commons that we've seen
so many times here that that will be
important as well yes and then what type
of psychometric profiles do you foresee
us sending what types of intelligence
what types of genders etc what-what
would be an ideal because you have to
live together for years well I think you
know gender max gender matches with
there will be men and women and
everything else that that entails so
will we you know will human beings have
been very inventive of you know dealing
with sexuality and that that will where
I'm not worried about that
in terms of the skill set there are so
many things particularly if you in the
early days when you you'll have a
relatively small crew just because of
the limit of how much mass you can send
there people are gonna have to be
trained in a variety of different skills
so you know in the book the movie the
Martian you know Mark Watney he was a
plant biologist a botanist but he was
also a mechanical engineer and you're
gonna need people who are a geologist
and engineers and you know electronics
specialists and computer specialists and
and so you're going to be multiple
trained and you know when you're talking
about a trip to Mars you're talking
probably two to three years so you know
what are the family circumstances under
which people will be willing to commit
three years of their lives with not a
hundred percent chance of coming back
alive either so it'll take a certain
breed of astronaut to do that but I have
no doubt that there many people out
there right now in the astronaut office
yeah you know if you said are you
willing to commit three years of your
life to go into Mars yes sir sign me up
you know yes you don't have trouble
finding people but but you better send
the right people the new four
enthusiasts sending over people Jeff how
about are we in a simulation
no I you're talking about alternate
universe and we're in a simulation of
somebody else's universe I don't even
know what that means you you tell me
what the observable consequences of
being a simulation of some alternative
universe that's what constitutes a
science theory is is an observable
consequence that can be either proven or
disproven
there's a lot of fascinating you know
even something like string theory which
is a very elegant mathematical theory of
elementary particles which I'm not an
expert in by any means but to my
understanding it still has not come up
with an observable prediction that would
allow us to you know confirm or disprove
it and so to be a real theory it has to
have observable consequences and you
know there's a lot of fascinating
philosophy about what constitutes a you
know simulation in an alternative
universe but I don't look at it as a
question which needs to be answered
because you haven't come up with any
anything that I can test and as a
scientist I deal with things that I can
test and measure and Tsun Tsun to
potentially change poke with the
scientific probe and the last question
is what do you believe is the most
beautiful thing in the world the most
beautiful thing in the world maybe
things that I've seen from out of the
world for me and I mean just the the
variety of always enjoyed watching
sunrises and sunsets here on earth but
from space I mean I took so many
pictures when when we got back those
were in the days of film and IIIi heard
from the people who worked in the
photography office at NASA they would
develop the pictures and they half of
these pictures or sunrises and sunsets
Hoffman must have been on this flight
you know so that was and and you know
the the beauty of the this the halo that
surrounds the earth at night the the
aurora which in orbit you actually fly
right through the aurora yeah just so
many things and
and just being able to look at the Stars
and from space they don't clincal stars
don't true there's no more twinkle
twinkle little star because you're above
the atmosphere and you can in one night
time part of your orbit see both the
northern cross and the Southern Cross
because you fly from the northern
hemisphere to the southern hemisphere
you can never do that on the surface of
the earth the earth is a beautiful
planet there's many beautiful places
that I've seen on the earth and try to
pick out one as the most but I've been
fortunate enough along with about
roughly well fewer than 600 other people
to have been able to see things from
from above it's you know like the old
Joni Mitchell song and you know clouds
I've seen clouds from both sides now
even looking at the thee and one of the
most beautiful things you do see looking
at clouds from the top is thunderstorms
the Lightning propagating around the
clouds I mean it's not individual
lightning strikes like we see from the
ground it's these incredible light shows
moving around and that that was probably
one of the most mesmerizing things that
we would see looking out the windows
where cities sprawl out and you know
yeah this is these are all gorgeous
profound realizations and I'm so
grateful that you join us on this show
to teach us about your life and journey
as a NASA astronaut as well as the Space
Systems design well I wish we had more
time we could you know we could talk
we'll have another love a portal have
another part where we can dive deeper
into all of this Jeff thank you again so
much been a pleasure to show we really
greatly appreciate you thank you
everyone for tuning in we would love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
share more content like this with other
people go and inspire your friends
families online communities co-workers
get people talking about space keep
people talking about what it's like
being an astronaut and all of these
shifts in our awareness that we can
experience and check out Geoff's links
below also check out the links below to
simulation to our show support the
artists entrepreneurs and organizations
around the world that you believe in and
go and build the
you sure everyone manifests your dreams
into the world thank you so much for
tuning in and we will see you soon